now we've written coefficients for me
and deities results right summer brutes
suburb roots two at a time subgroups 32
times on first however many at a time
all the way up until you get all of the
roots which we call it planted roots
right so I want to show you a couple of
hot applications like at the moment
you're used to questions like this
something like this and here based on
those coefficients a b c and d you can
say all right well alpha + beta + gamma
for this particular polynomial should be
in this case my nephew a and C la- DNA
cetera we've generalizes pants before
okay now you guys have seen the
questions whether they say okay well
then can you fire for instance for this
one to be something like this you know
if you do what maybe it's a BCS deeper
could you then go ahead and evaluate
what alpha squared plus B squared plus
gamma squared is you guys know it's just
it just involves some combination of
minus B on a coa and by this DNA right
so we've seen them before I'm going to
call it the simpler applications right
today and we're going to look at a bit
of a different way of looking at it it's
all applicable closet from the other way
of rail we're going to form some new
equations where the roots are related to
the roots of this equation but in
different ways okay so he's actually
we're gonna start will begin with this
general cutie and we're saying if it has
the roots alpha beta and gamma
what we're going to do is we're going to
form two new polynomial equations which
have roots that are related to these
roots okay so we'll do a simple one
first okay so this is fun for the
polynomial or this should have been
profound a form a holiday with roots got
the dot add for the first one we're
going to do rather than alpha beta gamma
what would happen if we had a polynomial
that had roots that were exactly twice
the size twice the magnitude of
something so to answer to v9n to gun
right we have look apart they will get
another different relationship to action
now what I want us to do is to see if
you go back to this original equation
I've it has been given to you in the
form in equal zero it's in general form
okay that means that if I want to
because it's not just an expression I
can actually do things to both sides ok
so to help us see what's going on I want
us to notice that if you take this guy
and you divide through every term by a
and you're going to get this Oliver
okay now what's useful about this is
that we know what beyond a CLA MDMA are
in relation to these guys right we know
exactly what they are in relation to
what the prints are okay for example be
on a that's an easy one right we would
normally say that the sum of roots is
not beyond a but minus VA right so this
is the negative of this summer's the
roots so in fact i can write that i can
take its take away for some of the roots
because i know they are i've just given
them names right alpha + beta + gamma
that's the coefficient of x squared and
generally speaking for a polynomial of
degree n i can say the coefficient of
the term X to the N minus 1 will always
have the sum of the roots like it could
be the original one could be the power 7
and then the X to the sixth Earl will
have the summer fruit as its coefficient
provided its Monica ok the next bit coa
that's nice this sign is the same that
is the sum of the roots in pairs like so
it's a suburb pairs so there are three
pairs that i can be between alpha beta
and gamma they are ya alpha gamma and
vinegar so there is the son of the pairs
of roots and that's the coefficient x
the last beer dla that is i'm up to the
last one it is the opposite side of the
product of roots yeah so this is minus
alpha beta now UK with that now I can
use this I can take advantage of this
because remembering that this is a
general kid every cubic looks like this
I can play this game and reduce this
trick on every Cuban if I know what the
roots are if I know what the reetar and
in this case i do then i can rewrite i
can make a new polynomial that fits that
no matter what these conditions are ok
so here's the way I'm going to do it
remembering that of a particular alpha
beta gamma that
using are tied to these values of a B
and C and I'm going to make a new
equation okay I'm going to go through
one at a time I want the sale summer
cares and the product except in this
case it's my alphabet speed up let's go
write the sum of roots is like alpha +
beta + gamma it's true alpha us together
what's together if you see I've got a
new polygon than that right so it's got
new routes namely these guys what's
great about this of course is that this
is entirely to the previous pollinator
original one right this summer roots is
exactly double there's some of roots of
the first polynomial I know what that
alpha plus beta plus gamma is what is it
it's just- be on it right like that's
just the standard result so this in fact
is with the two at the front it's minus
to be on a UK with that I can continue
going through I'm going to use this to
build this okay once i get so let's do
this suburb yeah that's cat ah almost I
just beyond to a ah that's so close um
okay let's do the summer pets and grits
um here we go now be careful right so
here's a pair of roots right so rather
than alpha beta I've got to alpha x 2
meter so they both appear so I'm
actually just to make sure I'd screw
this up I'm going to write it out in
long form so there's my first care and
here is my second planet and here's my
last
okay so you can see it doesn't take that
much imagination to see I'm still going
to get the same hairs of ruth the same
three but instead of just having one of
each i have four [ __ ] so I'm going to
take that for out the front okay now
again this is useful because I already
know what the sum of pairs of roots
should be based on the original equation
it's just going to be see mah name so
putting that together with the 4 i'm
getting four see and hear can you go
ahead can you do the product of really
touching
you can probably do it in one life what
is that product of roots yeah yeah yeah
so it's this times this type this right
which is it at two cubed alpha be
together but we know what alpha beta
gamma is from the original equation it's
minus D on it so that gives me minus
eight I doesn't yet to publicly before
so i would say summer fruit salad pairs
of roots some of triples of roots some
of quartets of roots pentomino shoot
yeah you just keep it i mean the the
general way of saying it rather using
this language is to say summer fruits
one at a time Salman routes to the time
some roots three at a time and sir okay
now what I want you to do and the the
critical thing here is that you don't
confuse the original polynomial with the
new polynomial that I'm writing okay i
have a new summer fruits and knew some
of pairs of roots and the new product of
roots each of these three numbers i got
to fit yeah yeah okay do you see because
this is a general cubic right every
cubic is going to be a behave like this
so therefore my dear qubit should also
perform the same way okay it's just that
my summoner its happens to be that so
let's go ahead you can say new
polynomial is
I have confidence of its monic so I
start with my excuse then I take away
take away the sum of the roots so watch
the double negative there right so this
is minus to be one hey that's the
coefficient of x squared I've got my son
of its to a time myself guess it's 40 mm
that's the coffee shop x and then excuse
me watch the double negative again minus
negative 8 d 18 that thing is equal to 0
okay now in some senses I'm kind of done
because who hired to do is for the
polynomial that's the polynomial but we
can tidy this up for two reasons number
one because it's a royal mess number two
cuz it's London general form number
three to see if we can see some kind of
pattern as to what doing this does to
open your polynomial ok so it's tiny to
stop early I whatever device you buy a
yr you sneeze naturally instead that I
could see it do you remember that like
that's to make it monic so that I can
see this but that's not in my interest I
actually wanted to go back to being
without fractions only the first thing I
want to do is multiply everything to you
by head and I might as well resolve what
my double negatives the same time so I'm
getting this
okay that's good now this point I notice
something unusual is happening which is
that I've got powers of X and then I
have powers of eight do you notice that
it's almost as though this some kind of
biome you'll think happening that
doesn't quite work out because this ABC
and D they have nothing to do with a
vintage completely random numbers as you
can see ok so in order to get them
rather than powers of X decreasing and
then powers of 2 increasing if i get
there to marry up to each other and i
can simplify this nicely so i'm going to
take every term and i'm going to divide
through by eight the reason for a three
by eight is because it's too cute and
you'll see what happens when i do this
so watch i'm going to get a times X
cubed on 8 i'm going to have be x
squared on what see X on do you see
what's happening and then all is left
there is d ok now you can see rather
than being in opposite directions the
powers of X and powers are too they
marry up ok so here's my last thing I'm
going to write this as x on two cute x
on to swear i've already got this one in
episode 22 and there's so I've
successfully got into general form l too
much in the tub and now my final
question was what does this have to do
with this have a look what's the
relationship when I double the roots
what happens to my polymer new look
they're all half every variable term has
the heart of course of course it does
because if I say something like oh can
you give me like a version of this right
you know where the roots are right there
at 0
25 can you give me a version of this
where the roots are twice the magnitude
instead of 0 plane cheap I i worked at 0
to PI and 4 pi well you should stretch
it out like that is exactly the same
right so this is just like mucking fuch
frequency in period accepted well
there's a frequency in period on a
polygon but the same sketching event so
therefore generally speaking right
that's I guess I didn't call this P
event but under the court papers now if
you have some polynomial P of X and you
want its roots to your afford a new
polynomial with rich say K alpha K beta
K gamma then the new polynomial will be
P of X on let that coefficient okay
right and that's why we have um probably
what necessarily I mean you can see is
actually a fair bit of work to
demonstrate understand George make you
jump there um I think it's better just
like new connex it's good to know that
so that when you get me like oh yeah of
course I got knew where I was heading
rather than remember how I introduced a
whole bunch of steps in your likewise
Audrina I white / that now you know why
cuz I was heading there